o sol subindo mais um vídeo e hoje fazer
uma coisa mais simples e relaxada que
montar um brinquedo esta catapulta do da
ela não foi muito utilizada na era
medieval mas é muito engraçado um
mecanismo e eu saí comprar e mostrar
para vocês e é isso que vou fazer hoje
vou montar esse tempo todo e mostrarmos
o funcionamento dela então bora lá
por começar vou abrir a caixa e depois
vou tirar o saco com as coisas da caixa
a faixa que é muito estranho em cima de
vocês perdem sempre vou falar nos vídeos
mas este vídeo não sai é muito simples
então sei lá acho que falar de outra
coisa porque esse projeto basicamente é
só encaixar essas partes madeiras umas
nas outras e estou usar uma cola para a
madeira que vinha já no quinto e tão só
eu vou voltar pro portugal e
provavelmente não interessa a ninguém e
quase é porque também não fala se muito
com vocês sobre as minhas coisas é
matematicamente voltar por portugal eu
mudar os meus planos e agora as coisas
vão ficar melhor o novo plano é a minha
realidade e mais vídeos vou tentar
produzir dois vídeos por semana e acho
que eu vou conseguir com nomes que eu
vou ter mais tempo e foi começar a
estudar online que assim desta maneira
eu vou conseguir estudar em qualquer
parte do mundo e assim vou conseguir
viajar que é uma coisa que eu sempre
quis fazer e acho que até agora e não
daqui a uns quatro anos se fosse uma
universidade é bastante tempo e que o
tempo vai passando muito rápido só então
fazer umas mudanças mas acho que talvez
eu faça um vídeo falar sobre isso
continuar em portugal e teve as coisas
mais ou menos montadas aí comprei esta
[ __ ] é numa política que estava escrito
que tem vendido bastante os exemplares e
as pessoas têm gostado muito ouvir
porque as pessoas gostaram porque tem
vários vídeos online e ouvi lá naquela
moradia vista que o topo é na internet e
as duas fizeram vários vídeos sobre ela
então isso ele comprar mais para frente
eu quero fazer uma versão mais simples
que vocês possam fazer em casa é nesta
parte que enganem porque o tio x com o
ponto de exclamação e aqui eu tinha sim
grande que eu encaixei no cilindro é eu
não devia ter colocado agora mas daqui
mais para frente que vocês vão ver que
eu vai desencaixado lá eu vou encaixar
outra vez
aí comecei a fazer uma versão mais
simples como fazer mas daqui a algum
tempo para não ser seguida este vídeo aí
fazer este vídeo agora e depois talvez
aqui umas duas três maneiras de fazer
uma versão que você possa fazer em casa
utilizando rolhas potentes picolé
populam instituto de coisas aí por que
vocês deixem ficar na cola antes de
começar a preparar a hitachi ficarei
mais ou menos duas horas antes de
começar a usar que disputa esta peça
aqui é muito importante porque que
colher vai embater e eles também
colocaram aqui na esponja para fazer uma
amortização do impacto
aí agora fazer projetos mais simples
tamanho salto porque o tenho visto é
complicar um pouco as coisas e algumas
pessoas não estão a gostar disso porque
elas não podem fazer em casa uma vez que
ele sempre me template já algumas coisas
mais difíceis de encontrar
então eu vou tentar fazer um balanço
entre o projeto difíceis em projetos
mais simples como fazia no início
este político grandes aqui eles são
feitos de bambu e são muito elásticos e
eu não sei como fizeram e catapultas ou
usar o outro de bambu ou outra coisa mas
boxer mais para frente mas este é um
projeto simples de fazer o que são
materiais preciosos está muito a minha
maneira de falar e começa a falar uma
coisa e salto para o outro e volta a
falar pra outra e eu realmente o preciso
ir a um curso para aprender a falar das
minhas habilidades comunicativas nunca
foram as melhores
são mais de ter idéia de pensar em si
próprio e que está terminado solo será
muito bacana mesmo é que mais os testes
em e este brinquedo traziam uma toxina
que vocês podem fazer bolinhas ea mandar
e pronto só temos assim é esperto no
estado
se você tiver alguma sugestão de algum
projeto podem deixar os comentários que
eu vou vendo vou sentar na minha lista e
depois vou fazer mais para a frente a
isso cria-se uma coisa aqui isso não é
um
o vídeo é patrocinadora pessoal isto é
só uma coisa que eu comprei e sabe
trazer para vocês verem como é muito
obrigado por escrito só até a próxima se
vocês podem deixar lá e eu agradeço isso
ajuda bastante button